well brooke you've got our next story oh
i do okay so here's a question what
can a man's pet tell you about his
commitment to monogamy well there's a
new survey and it says that men with
certain pets admit to cheating more than
others so best life reports 3 000 men
were surveyed by the pet website moggy
and doggy and they found the men most
likely to cheat were those who owned pet
rabbits and hamsters
wow
okay trust a man that had a hamster i
will say i do find this kind of
fascinating like i don't like men
cheaters and now like apparently they
have rabbits and hamsters yeah and
evidently the
men that don't have pets are less likely
to admit to cheating now that you've
heard this story if you met a man who
had a rabbit and a hamster
would you would you both both yeah
would you give it a go uh
what if he promised he could make you
very very happy
[Applause]
you make women laugh and the next thing
you know
um okay well next we've got an
interesting debate that i want to get
your take on brooke parents magazine
reports that school photo companies are
offering retouching services on kids
school photos there's been a backlash
from parents who say it sends the wrong
message to kids one mom posted this pic
the photo company had photoshopped out
her child's freckles
and then she tweeted asking to get them
back other parents say they see a place
for it and one person said their son got
scratched by their cat on his face just
days before the annual photo and they
wish they had been able to fix it brook
thoughts i don't think that it's the
right message i really don't i think
it's not fair because you're telling
you're sending the child a message that
says you're not good enough so we're
going to fix you you're something's
wrong with you we're going to fix you
and if you're starting that young god
help them by the time they're older
completely yes
i i hate this for for little kids i will
say
like 16 17 there are a couple pictures i
wouldn't mind a little photoshop on from
my past you know what i mean like a
thing here and a thing here and a thing
when you look back and you're like that
was when i had feathered hair and a perm
and it's so hideous it's just it's a
part it's a marked period of your life i
don't feel like and you're not that
anymore so and i don't know i think
they're funny i think brookshield's
changed my mind i think now i know i'm
going to embrace those pictures when i
had terrible hair but then look but look
at it now it's gorgeous you know what
brook shields you have a great point
thank you so much
i just have to tell you that here's what
i'm thinking as you guys are talking is
brooke you and the nothing comes between
me and my calvin's campaign
like at the time when high school photos
are being taken there you are
in your jeans with your shirt and that
body language i mean and the hair
blowing out the most iconic
it is
that
is fashion campaign
legendary legacy history
you know we got really lucky i think
that we had you can't set out to do like
now people photographers say we're going
to do some iconic photos and you're like
oh really oh good that's good to know
you can't set out to do an iconic photo
it either happens or it doesn't fly on
the wall moment of that day i mean
literally that is like the campaign that
just it changed the world what any we
had we did a minute long commercial and
i had to memorize this is like they
didn't have cue cards or teleprompters
or anything and i had to memorize a
monologue that was a minute long and
they were intending to play it during
movies
like before the coming attractions
and at the last minute they pulled it
because they said you'll never see a
coming uh you know an advertisement in a
movie now you can go like an hour late
and the movie hasn't even started
but uh the next day i got to high school
and there was a pop quiz and the quiz
the question was what's a gene and so i
re repeated my whole monologue and i got
an a you did
i need that photograph it's just it's
burned in my brain forever okay and
finally it is time for a pick from the
little yellow book which is my personal
curation of things i love that i want to
share with you
and today it couldn't be more special
because it's a special pick from brooke
so
show us what you got well it's over
there
and i thought it was appropriate because
i started a company called beginning is
now
and this is my sweatshirt the fun
beautiful color yellow
you put it on i've got one i know i've i
sent you one
that's the one yeah absolutely and i
have one too i don't know where mine is
but um
i will wear
i love it on the hood
so it's my
company
i love you i love you
i started this company i started it for
women um over 40 because i feel like as
we as we mature
we don't get represented we're not
represented i feel stronger sexier more
in my own skin now than i ever did in my
20s and then you go and you're not
marketed to you know and i want to
change that so beginning is now
[Applause]
brooke
i love you
i love you so much
a castle for christmas is on netflix now
it is everything and you'll see brooke
and i who have known each other our
whole lives finally acting together
although it's not about me it's all
about her
[Music]
you